my man kevin stewart was making a lot of
money as a professional football player
but he wanted to get into property and
he didn't know how to get started
so we sat down together in january 2020
we mapped out a plan and here is exactly
what happened
next so the question is do you start
small and build up i think probably not
i think you just get the training and
support
and you do a big deal straight off but
just do it very carefully
yeah risk assess every step of the way
and i think that's what we can talk
about
what you said is i think having an
apartment building is maybe the same
energy as
having one house so i think rather than
having loads of houses scattered around
i can have
a lot of houses just in one area yeah
and what we all look to do as well is
build an apartment box
yeah first thing you can do is not ask
for help when you get stuck yeah
that's it yeah because you will get
stuck yeah and everything you know but
when you get stuck
ask for help whether that's my team and
stuff whether it's finding people on the
academy that
look like anthony for instance go out
for a day with me
and go out for a day with at least two
other people that
that are experienced that are on the
academy um that are that they've got a
good track record i'll
keep some people so by the summer you
should have
a deal big deal where you it's in the
bag offer accepted
whether it's a joint venture if it's not
a joint venture you could do it alone
but make sure you've got support
maybe yeah consultants or whatever yeah
but we can just we can see what's best
yeah i think my first one would probably
be enjoying it fine and then i think
from from the
summer to the winter it's just going to
be a case of um
completing the build yeah the progress
that's going to be fun
and get out there once a month with a
yellow hard hat
see the progression be learning like
crazy and
the deal needs to be in all your money
in and all your money out
leaving you with a passive income
perfect
and guess what he did get the yellow
hard hat well not yellow it was white
but he did build an apartment block he
built an apartment block with 48
apartments in birmingham
and now he's financially set for life
and right now
he's going to share with you the story
of exactly how he did it
and how the process went down he's a
professional
football player he's played for teams
like hall
city tottenham liverpool blackpool
incredible football player but also an
incredible
property investor he's got some really
crazy deals going on
so he's going to tell you a story of
exactly what he's done how he's done it
kevin welcome to the show bro thanks for
having me
so many uh winners wednesdays it feels a
bit surreal to actually be on one
well there we go i mean you've been on
my youtube channel before though we've
been out on the road
doing big deals and looking at stuff but
um
tell me the story like you're a
professional football player as you know
i coach quite a lot of football players
usually they don't physically come to my
crash course like you did
yeah but you broke your leg and turned
up
so tell me what happened yeah well not
too bad it wasn't that dramatic i did uh
had an operation on my fifth metatarsal
so it wasn't as uh as bad
but yeah literally it was strange but
i've been watching your content for a
long time
before that and i was like no i'm never
gonna have to come to a crash course
because you know i'm always playing
football
and then an injury came about i found a
positive in it and i was like as soon as
i realized you know i'm gonna be out for
a little while i'm like first thing i'm
doing is going to the crash course
yeah um so i was you know i was buzzing
about that came down
um literally the day after my operation
on on crutches front row
and it was amazing man so that's that
there really kick started everything for
me where i really started to
um find you know my feet and you know
how the property
world works you know collaborations and
that's when i really started opening out
and start
the the biggest thing i probably took
away from the crash course is the
importance of you know just putting
yourself out there and networking
yeah yeah building relationships which
is in the football world is not
you know it's uh it's not really like
that it's really secretive and
you know kind of staying your own lane
only mixed with with footballers
it's kind of like that so it's been like
really refreshing coming into the
property well
yeah being in a different industry yeah
and i remember when we met as well you
know you came down with your dad
um you joined you're in the academy and
your cousin
yeah you joined the you guys join the
academy yeah which which was awesome
we've spent quite a bit of time together
since then for the last year and a half
we've been going out together
we've been on the road a few times
messaging back and forth
um when we when you first joined the
academy
we had a conversation which i think
actually made it to youtube it was like
a coaching conversation
um what what happened what was the part
what was the game plan
um well from from then i'll say i was
very very refreshed to it so
that was almost just it was amazing for
me because it's like an hour i can sit
down with you and kind of just pick your
brains and
really be um really specific to me on
what you know you think i should do
moving forward
so you know we sat down for an hour you
gave me um you know a lot of
advice and kind of direction from there
know
when you first join property and you go
to the crash course there's so many um
different strategies so i was like i
want to do this i want to do that i want
to do this i want to do that
but as well it can be sometimes a bit
dangerous at times when you know
you're not you know got too much
knowledge and it's so much going around
and getting overwhelmed
so um i think from there the idea for me
was to come
come there and then leave with more of a
strategy more of a focus
and that's that's what um and i remember
saying to you as well i was saying like
because one of the reasons you you told
me you're like i want to join the
academy because i want access to the
people
yeah i want you to network with people
you had some money you know making good
money as
a footballer you say you've saved him a
few hundred thousand pounds and you
thought i want to invest it wisely
um so that when i finish football one
day i'll be i'll have a portfolio and
i'll be able to continue living a good
life is that fair to say
yeah exactly and um and i was like dude
everyone's gonna pitch you yeah
everyone's gonna pitch you you know i
mean like a premier football player
made a lot of money you're on the
academy you're putting yourself out
there
you're gonna get people pitching you
with deals trying to sell you deals
trying to joint venture with you on
deals
and i said you've got to be really picky
because i said
your problem is not what you invest in
but it's what you don't invest in
yeah um did that happen yeah no for sure
and even before that
you know with me when i lacked it when i
want to do something i'm just like
quite fearless and i'll just go and do
it so even before we had that chat
i almost bought two very average
properties in
uh in whole at the time so it's a good
thing it takes long to actually buy a
house or yeah i would have just brought
these two houses
um so that actually was a big bonus for
me
when i came there and i got a little
better advice
but yeah from that from then as well
moving forward after that there's
so many opportunities to you know get
involved in deals and build some deal
sources
um that you know before i would have
very easily just just done it just to
get involved i was really keen to get
involved and
i'm someone who just like almost starts
now get perfect later
yeah but i thought that could be
something a little bit a little bit
dangerous
at times and it'll probably take me
longer to get to my goals about
actually where i want to be totally and
as well like
i want to get on to what you've done
because you're actually you're building
a whole bunch of apartments which is
incredible you've got service
departments as well
um but with a few hundred grand you
could very easily just go and buy one
house
yeah yeah rent it out say oh i don't
want to have a mortgage you don't want
to have debt
yeah and make peanuts from it yeah so so
talk with
and you're one of the few people as well
because there's a lot of sports people
but you're one of the few people that
actually dedicated like 12 months
to say i'm going to study i'm going to
learn i'm going to go out i'm going to
network
i'm going to read the books attend the
seminars and you immersed yourself in
the world of property and now your
knowledge is like really good
we can have a very very intelligent
conversation we'll bounce ideas off each
other
um you know so so what what was that
immersion look like what kind of what
kind of sacrifices did you make that
most people would not be prepared to
um i think i think just just just
countless hours on just youtube just
like
continuously like follow you my missus
is probably the best person to ask
because
she's been on the back end of it you
know yeah she wants to spend
time together or for her if you want to
spend time every night doing something
watching tv whatever
or going out but there's so many times
where i'm like studying so hard i'm like
look
you know it's a bit of a battle
sometimes where she wants to do one
thing i've got
i want to study and do all the things
but she gets it
so um you know just countless hours
really kind of star wars and obviously
having the courage to go out and meet
new people and go into
an industry where you don't really know
what you're doing and you don't really
know what you're talking about
and um you know just sometimes looking
and sounding like an idiot because yeah
just starting out so i think um yeah
that's i think what stops a lot of
people from immersing themselves into a
different
you think so you think they don't want
to ask a stupid question they don't want
to be judged
yeah so they just say nothing can keep
quiet and don't grow or
learn yeah yeah but for me properly
literally this is something that i'll do
forever yeah and it's definitely a
career that i'll you know
probably go full time in after i finish
playing so all them restrictions
i knew for a fact i was going to push
through whatever came
came about because what's on the other
side that's too important for me
yeah so i can never see myself being
stopped by things like that so
what's the crack as well with like
because we've had this conversation
before and you've said about some of my
other people i'm coaching sports people
whereby they have to be really
careful i've said they have to be really
careful on not appearing to be not
committed to their profession as
a sportsman yeah what what's your kind
of take on all that
uh i think it's [ __ ] i think it can
i swear
yeah you can you can what do you mean
what do you think i think it's unfair i
think it's unfair
when uh you know when people from the
outside or
in to be it's probably worse inside the
industry as well
where they make out as if you know you
can't do two things at once
because you're gonna get distracted from
this one thing but um
i definitely think you can you can
easily do both
um and just don't think it's fair
because you know football's a very short
career
and you probably you're all aware of the
stats of how many footballers go broke
after they finish playing
scary so they've got to look after them
so they've got to protect themselves
they've got to take their families
so um you know for someone to
to hold that against a footballer but
you know preparing himself for the
future i think is a bit is a bit unfair
but
at the same time you know it's down to
the the player to
push through those boundaries yeah
because you're dedicated man like with
you training you're training every day
we spend a day on the road
you eat really disciplined yeah he's got
you're a good influence on me
yeah um
[Laughter]
you're completely dedicated but then in
any of you when you've got a bit of
spare time
you're going to be on the road viewing
houses immersing yourself in content
yeah on the phone to me or someone or or
whatever so um
okay so talk me through your first deal
because your first it was a big deal
yeah massive deal straight in what's
that i went straight in right you went
straight into the defense but you went
straight in but you went in educated
with your eyes open
yeah very edgy good people around me as
well yeah
told me talk me through this deal yeah i
think that's important thing so it was a
funny one to be fair so before that
um you know we were talking about doing
a deal together we weren't even talking
about we pretty much agree with doing it
we had like
well we had like the loan project all
the yeah coming into it um
it was close to doing it but um so at
the time
around that time i kind of knew what i
wanted to do i definitely wanted to do
large apartment buildings yeah whether
that was to buy an already existing one
or to build them
i didn't mind i've always been quite
fond of buildings like that
um so obviously i didn't really have any
opportunities to get involved in deals
like that i just wanted to do something
you know just get a taster or something
quick victory could win
um be a part of something so basically
just for a bit of context
you're getting really educated you're
learning but you you
you realized that a big deal was going
to be just as much effort as a small
deal
so you went to getting on a big deal but
because you didn't have the full
experience you thought you'd
go in with your eyes open with education
but you joint venture
with someone me or whoever on someone
else's big deal
as a jv you were getting pitched all the
time
you after you've done quite a bit of
training you came to me
i brought a deal we got we started going
ahead yeah
and we were like cool man contracts
weren't signed
but it was like yeah you're doing it
yeah yeah and i was it was literally
like
well maybe a day or two off off from
doing it um
and then um anthony laville who i met
for your youtube channel
yes i reached out to him yeah i met him
in birmingham he showed me around a few
of his sites that he was doing
um with literally no regards to doing
the deal together whatsoever i was more
just i think he was
doing me a favor you know and he was
someone who i can just call just like
how i am with you that can ask a
question um so then it was kind of like
that and then literally two days before
i was about to do something he called me
up and said oh by the way i've got this
opportunity
and that you might like because he knew
i was quite fond of um develop
development and you know large apartment
buildings like i've got something
perfect for you um so straight away i
was like wow
like this is this is amazing as long as
the deal stacks up and even at that time
i don't even have to read the
development door
calculate risk or anything like that so
i actually passed that on to you
and i knew that we were doing a deal
together so if you gave me the the go
ahead for that deal i knew it was a good
deal because
you know you wouldn't for you to do that
you'd have to you couldn't be biased
because you really had to do it that we
was doing
yeah and you couldn't do both yeah i
couldn't do both you had a limited
amount of funds
yeah yeah so the fact that even though
we was about to do a deal
you turned around and said no this is a
really good deal you know anthony's
done due diligence um work is solid
i was like for me you know you and
and ben as well for me that was um
enough
that i needed to you know start looking
at it properly and look to fully go into
it
that's so good and then you're like
sorry dude i'm actually gonna go for
this other deal
but but how did i react oh no you was
like
you almost pushed me onto it yeah yeah
cause you for you often you knew it was
it was a good opportunity for me yeah
because for me i just think it's really
important
um number one as a mentor you paid me
you joined the academy to be your mentor
so i need to be completely 100
um unbiased yeah and just be like you've
brought this other deal to me
it's irrelevant that what we've got
going on is it does this stack i looked
i said it looks great
stacks went through the gdv all the
different costings looked at it
obviously i know anthony he's a cool guy
um but also
like the bigger your win is
the better for me exactly yeah yeah you
know because we wouldn't have this story
without it
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know so i think
i think that's really important
so you went ahead with the deal you
bought a piece of rubble yeah which
effectively is what it was
a mountain of rubble a mountain of
rubble which is in birmingham city
center
yeah so what's happened since um
so since then we kind of from when i got
involved we got him moving quite
quite quickly um so
from then we started we started building
so we got it we got it all tied up all
done probably just before lockdown
um and then we probably started building
you know actually can't remember the
month we started building
um but a good maybe
maybe maybe maybe around
um last shh
i can't remember i can't remember them
off he started yeah but but but in the
last sort of 12 months in the last yeah
in the last sort of 12 months so
it's due for completion august 10th so
you know go over a year a year back so
what does it look like now when you when
you bought it
now a big big mountain of rumors it's
amazing that i went from just
land rubble um to this huge building
yeah you know we only got probably a
floor left to build um
so the transformations how many floors
is it
um it's five five floors you've built
four floors
yeah you've got the top ones the roof
yeah so you should be finished the next
kind of couple couple two three months
yeah yeah um and then
you put about 300 grand into that um
originally originally that i put up at
300 grand you put a little bit more
a little bit more in and how much profit
are you expecting to make of that deal
once it's done
uh now i know you're going to keep it
you're not going to sell it but if you
did sell it yeah yeah so you know if
if if all goes to plan you know it gets
values
to plan um we'll be looking at
one point eight in total i'm i'm i'm
half with
with my partner it's crazy good it's yes
it's big returns it's crazy good so talk
me through some of the lessons
i mean you've spent countless hours
educating yourself you've been out on
the road
you've been you know obviously you've
been doing this project
talking through some of the lessons and
the learning curves that have happened
um i think one of the one of the big
ones
which i mentioned to you earlier is i
think when you're doing a deal of that
size
and you're new to it as well it's very
hard it's very easy to get distracted by
other projects
so at the time before that i was so keen
to get involved and even though i got
involved in
that project i still had this
eagerness to go and do other things um
so this was you know before covered and
then um
good advice that i i got from anthony
was you know when you're doing big deals
like this and you've got
you know this big prize that's here
don't get too distracted by other
things that could you know jeopardize
this
big deal that you've got yeah um so you
know it's easy to spread yourself too
thin and
um go and do a lot of other things and
you know something happens
and you know you've got to use maybe
funds to support
the bigger deal that you're not spread
too thin doing other little deals that
are
you know all in order to distract you
from the big yeah time and money right
yeah you time money up on lots of little
deals you can get
exhausted running around on the little
deals and then you missed it you missed
you missed a big thing
so you're working on that nine hundred
thousand pound profit yeah
which is amazing yeah yeah it's it's
really amazing i know you've got some
other deals as well you've got some like
service departments and things like that
um but what would you say what's the
plan then for you now like what's the
next
12 months two years looking like um
so i obviously successfully finished off
this this project
um and i think go go on to do
to do some of those yeah so whether that
be um
development or you know purchasing
like commercial to resist refurbs
on a bigger scale um yeah
i think i think that just go on build up
scale up theories one of the things we
spoke about about 18 months ago
when you you know we had our coaching
session was
i said to begin with jump in on other
people's deals
use their experience their credit and
and
but your education so you're going in
not blind but then once you've done that
deal
you should then start bringing other
people into your deals yeah yeah now
over the last 12 months as you've become
more and more educated
more and more successful in property um
you've been having quite a few people
reach out to you right
yeah yeah yeah talk to me about that um
so
i think it's come from come from where
you know you know i've had a lot of
other athletes
other football players reach out and um
you know they're quite
quite intrigued as to what i'm doing and
you know i've got opportunities that
possibly they can get involved in
um a lot of friends families and just
you know just
you know how social media is a lot of
people that see what you're doing
because i post about it
quite quite often as well um so there's
a lot of people that are intrigued
in terms of what i do so when they reach
out you know
try and figure out if there's any other
things i have that they can get involved
in
um so you know i'm constantly looking
always and i'm definitely planning on
bringing a lot more people into
the things i'm doing a way to you know
give people who don't have the access
into property or they don't have the
time
so um you know i've sat across a lot of
time to learn
learn the game so not a lot of people
are able to do that or willing to do
that
yeah i think i'm maybe a lot more
qualified to
you know invest their money properly
than they are yeah and you've had people
you know you've had some big football
players reach out to you and they're
like oh i'm looking at doing this deal
and you've looked at it you've been able
to actually don't do that or do do that
and you've been able to kind of advise
people what's best
based on the experience the training the
knowledge that you've built up which is
a really
you know powerful position to be in yeah
yeah i think
that's a one thing that i've got from
you as well you know trying to be
someone with value
so um i think that is also what makes
the sacrifice a little easier in terms
of you know study and
all the time and getting yourself out
there and just learning learning the
game is that you become so valuable to
other people yeah
um so i think that's been a massive help
in terms of you know
pushing me to go out and learn more and
do bigger things
what would your advice be to other
football players and sports people
that may be thinking i haven't got the
time or the inclination or maybe
they have but they're that they're
thinking about property like what was it
that
pulled you into property why are you so
excited about it
um i think i
i think one of the different strategies
you know there's so many different ways
to make money in property but
in in general i just think you know i
think it's the best vehicle for building
wealth
i think it goes hand in hand with
a lot of um people in different fields
like football for example
a lot a lot of property can be quite
passive and quite hands-off not
completely completely but you know um
it's a way to you know
put put your money somewhere and you can
almost you ain't got paid too much
attention to it sometimes
um and then just you know the bases are
probably the fact that it's probably
gonna
outlive all of us it's something you can
pass down to your kids something you can
see
physically it's bricks and water yeah um
not like you know like stocks
stocks and shares that you can't
actually physically see yeah
um and just the returns as well some of
the returns you can get you know
you know huge and it pays you monthly
you can leverage it with their you know
so many different strategies to it yeah
yeah i think i like it
and also as well like we've we've spent
quite a bit of time together i've
introduced you to some cool people
you know um ben we've been out on start
with ben and janet
and we've been to big properties small
properties like
what would you say to somebody that's
that's trying to network that's trying
to get in
you know and and meet the right people
because i think network is really
important what best tips would you give
to being able to get in with the right
people
um i think i think you've got a drop
you know i think a lot of people are
quite fearful in terms of meeting new
people and just reaching out
so i think you kind of you've got to
kind of leave that behind to be
successful at it
you know some people you reach out some
people aren't going to get back to you
some people are
um but as well i think try and find a
way to be to be valuable
to somebody else you know you might
think that you know because you don't
have much knowledge or even funds for
example that you're not going to be
um that valuable to somebody else but
there's always
something you have that someone else
probably don't have yeah so find a way
to be valuable
find a way to you know get into the room
i think there's a
there's a good saying i don't actually
know for sure but you know something
like
if you can't if you can't get seat at
the table serve water into the room
something like that it's really cool
it's a really cool one i heard on
youtube it's really cool
yeah you know just find a way to to to
you know
get involved with the right people a lot
what you've talked about as well is
about fear i think people are
afraid to step into new circles afraid
to reach out afraid to
drop someone a dm on instagram and be
like can we chat
afraid to look stupid afraid to ask a
question which makes it look like
they're ignorant but actually when you
just get over that fear
yeah and put yourself out there and go
look man i want to do property
everything you want is i think
on the other side of here for sure yeah
yeah because i
well in terms of just reaching out all
the opportunities i've had has just been
from me reaching out to somebody
yeah so the deal with the birmingham
door i'm building 48 apartments that's
just coming from you reaching out to
anthony from seeing them on your youtube
channel that's all it was yeah so i
think that's that's really vital why did
you like service accommodation so much
um it's the cash flow yeah the cash flow
it's what i tonight is straight i find
it's like a bit of a game it's like um
it's a bit unpredictable it's good and a
bad thing i guess but
you know it's it's a bit of a game where
you know on a monthly basis you know how
much can you
how much can you get how many bookings
can you get um so i think i like that
that's how i do i find that side of it
quite quite interesting
yeah so there's obviously risk to it but
there's also a big reward to it
um so no no no no normal house you might
get
700 pound rent but you know if you're
running on out on a nightly basis
you can get up to you know two grand to
another people just don't realize
that there is another way you can do
joint ventures you can rate your
property out
as a service accommodation we're in one
right now yeah yeah
you know but when you realize and when
you get trained um
suddenly opportunities start rising well
do you know
so we spent quite a lot of time but a
lot a lot of when i see you is online
yeah so you know it's always it's i
always find it really interesting you
know when i watch all your stuff
and i watch you making videos and when i
actually meet you in person i see you
making videos it's a bit like
i find the funniest what do you mean um
just you know i've watched so many
videos so many hours
yeah on uh on on youtube and when you
actually see you in person
you know going around and doing these
videos like when we met um
jl today yeah you know i can just
visualize you putting out on youtube
it's just a
bit of a it's a funny moment yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but now it's been amazing it's literally
like i think a similar life to what i'm
going to live
when i when i finish playing you know
you're on the road a lot you know you're
going around
meeting people connecting with people
looking at deals so it's a life i find
like
super interesting and i just like the
fact you know you make your own program
yeah so you know you um
you control your own time and you you
decide where you want to be today
tomorrow
and you kind of have it mapped out which
i really i really like the idea of
yeah so um another thing as well is with
all the people reaching out to you
you know that want to do deals and
they're like man
help me help me do a big deal i want to
build 48 apartments
um what's the best way to find these
types of opportunities to find these
types of deals
um to be fair i don't think enough
people reach out like that they want to
start smaller
yeah but not because they want to do
smaller deals i just think because they
feel like they're just not qualified to
do a bigger deal
which if you like i said if you get
around the right people it doesn't
actually
i'm not qualified to do a deal like that
by myself yeah but
you know if i can find value to someone
who is
you know you partner up and and you uh
and you do that
so um my advice just find someone who's
doing what you want to do
so um you know if you're into
development find someone who is in you
know six months ahead of you or
ten years ahead of you you know find
value
but as well you'd be surprised how many
people just want to help just how many
people just
would just take a 10-minute phone call
just to help you out because they know
that when they first started how helpful
that would have been to them so
yeah people in the property wildman are
like so helpful it's unbelievable
oh yeah massively it's the whole
environment i think of property
investors is wanting to see other people
when certainly
in our world yeah you know um that's
certainly the kind of environment and
culture
that i try and i try and create um so
football property pros and cons to being
a footballer first property investor
um pros and cons
so well football's short yeah i think
obviously property game is
you know in it for the long run so you
can you know do it forever
yeah um pros
of i think it's really
i think it's more excitement in the
football world
yeah you know people don't i mean
there's people don't see all the um
the sacrifices in football as well but
there's more of an excitement on a daily
basis because you know you're doing
something exciting all the time where
there's
times in property where it's very boring
you've got to
do the due diligence and the long work
and you know the excitement at the end
of the project
when you've got everything ticked off um
something they're probably the what best
moment
in history in your football career and
best moment in your property career good
question i say my best moment
in football is probably when i when i
played against barcelona
for liverpool and i played against some
of the best players
ever you know like messy busquets
um that's probably my my favorite moment
um and in property
um without sat down without signing
buyers
the first thing that comes to my head
was probably going to the crash course
it was really it was a real kickstarter
and just like it was
it was like a really like uh moment was
like wow like this i'm going to do this
this is
something i'm going to do forever yeah
so i think that it gave me that kind of
energy so that and i think
the last time i went to birmingham to
see the project and i stood on top of it
and i was like wow like you stood on it
yeah this is mine
you're building 48 apartments yeah did
you know when you came to the crash
course
that within just over a year you'd have
built forty eight years
no chance no chance i mean at the time
from the crash course when i left
you know i was looking at batolettes i
was looking at um
you know small refurbs two bedroom
houses
that wasn't even in my my thought
process but then you know being around
other people i kind of got challenged
to just to look bigger and that's
something that anthony kind of
drilled into me as well just like just
to think bigger yeah because at the time
um yeah i think when you start off with
something you always feel like you have
to just start
smalling and work your way up but
there's other ways of doing things you
know there's not just
one way so um i think that opened i can
wind up massively and i'm happy that i
made that jump
well dude man it's been pleasure to work
with you favorite footballer today i
think
yeah well i need to come and watch you
though man i can't wait for lockdown to
lift
yeah yeah you need to come i need to
come yeah yeah yeah i think they're
allowing fans in in like mid-may i think
well i'm super excited and uh thanks for
coming on the show man
please having me it's great to share and
inspire other people because
a lot of people that are successful that
want to keep it to themselves yeah
start making money having success and
they think i'm going to keep this to
myself whereas
you know you in the same way as me open
share
talk about what you're doing to inspire
other people bring other people in on
the journey
so i really respect that and uh it's
just been a blast working with you man
no it's been amazing
appreciate it bro i love you so much
thank you there we go that's the story
from my man kev
just do me a favor smash the like button
show some love for kev
he's an incredible guy he doesn't need
to come on winners on a wednesday you
know
he's making a lot of money he's got a
lot of games a lot of training
but he's done it just to inspire you so
that you can do the same thing too so
that you can become successful
to share about the mindset the
practicalities the skills
so give him a follow on instagram also
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel
you can subscribe up here if you want to
watch more winners on a wednesday's
interviews
i've got over a hundred you can check
out the entire playlist right here
and i look forward to hopefully seeing
you the property investors crash course
real soon thanks for watching peace out
god bless
[Music]
you